Trascrizione: Sara Capobianco
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Preferireste coltivare un futuro
costruito sulle individualità
o sulla socialità?
Ognuno di voi dovrebbe essere libero
di scegliere per sé stesso,
perché ognuno di voi conosce perfettamente
quali sono le esperienze  di vita
che volete, che desiderate vivere,
e quelle che volete evitare.
Penso capiti anche a voi,
di fermarvi ad osservare
le vostre giornate
e accorgersi di essere bombardati
da un'infinità di informazioni,
stimoli, notizie.
Trovarvi con così tanti impegni
da non riuscire ad avere
il tempo di respirare.
Essere in ansia,
per la consegna di un progetto.
Preoccupati, perché avete
un appuntamento importante;
ma dovete attraversare la città,
e c'è l'ora di punta del traffico.
Tutti aspetti, e stimoli,
che durante una giornata
spesso si sommano:
e il nostro autocontrollo va in tilt.
In questi momenti, è normale
desiderare un po' di calma,
prendere distanza da tutto e da tutti,
cercare di trovare il tempo
per rimanere da soli:
è normale.
Ma attenzione!
Questo è anche il momento in cui inizi
a coltivare dei semi di individualità.
Voglio farvi una domanda:
secondo voi,
se io nel mio terreno della vita
pianto semi di individualità,
cosa pensate che raccolgo
quando daranno i loro frutti?
Raccoglierò solitudine.
Io oggi sono qui, e vi parlo di cohousing.
Che tradotto, significa:
coabitare insieme.
Alcuni di voi vorrebbero dirmi: cosa?
Io abitare con altre persone in casa?
No!
Altri: esperienza già fatta
quando studiavo fuori,
e condividevo l'appartamento
con altri studenti.
Voglio fare chiarezza.
Il cohousing non è la casa
del Grande Fratello,
dove tutti condividono gli stessi spazi
nello stesso momento.
Né tantomeno quel contratto d'affitto
che hai firmato per la camera
con uso di cucina, bagno e lavanderia.
Il cohousing è l'opportunità
di adottare, e di tramandare,
un modello di abitare
all'insegna della sostenibilità.
Una sostenibilità
dove gli spazi condivisi,
e gli spazi privati,
si fondono insieme,
per dare vita a una sostenibilità
che guarda oltre i benefici dell'ambiente,
una sostenibilità che fa riscoprire
il valore delle condivisioni
e delle relazioni,
dove grazie a un'economia circolare
risparmi tempo e denaro.
Questo non è un modello
di ultima generazione:
fa parte di noi, da sempre.
I primi esseri umani lo hanno adottato
per necessità di sopravvivenza.
In tante aree del nostro pianeta,
fa parte della loro cultura.
Per noi, oggi, è l'opportunità
di poter scegliere consapevolmente
tra i tanti modelli
che si stanno diffondendo
in tutto il mondo.
Voglio condividere con voi alcuni dati.
Negli Stati Uniti, sono già 100.000
le persone che hanno scelto
questo modello.
Nel Nord Europa, dove il primo gruppo
si è formato negli anni '60,
sono già più di 5.000.
Anche in Italia stiamo crescendo:
si stima che siamo
intorno alle 1000 persone,
per lo più nel Centro Italia.
Ma si stanno, veramente, diffondendo
modelli in tutto il nostro Paese.
La mia esperienza di cohousing
nasce nel 1964, anno in cui sono nata.
Certo, c'è da dire
che nascere in quegli anni,
in un piccolo borgo dell'Umbria
dove sì, ero immersa
nella natura meravigliosa
ma anche dove gli abitanti
conoscevano tutto di tutti -
E quando vi dico:
"tutti conoscevano di tutto",
vi assicuro: era proprio così.
Mia mamma, quando ero bambina,
non si preoccupava mai
se mi allontanavo da sola
per le vie del borgo:
tanto ci sarebbe stata un'altra mamma,
una nonna, una zia, la vicina
attenta a capire con chi giocavo,
dove ero entrata,
da quali persone mi ero fermata a parlare,
se avevo parlato con uno sconosciuto,
quanto mi ero allontanata da dove abito;
e poi, lo raccontava a mamma.
Certo, molti di voi ora
potrebbero pensare:
che ansia a vivere così!
Lo immagino: meno male che vivo da solo
nel mio appartamento, nella mia casa,
e non conosco nemmeno i miei vicini.
Posso essere d'accordo con voi.
Infatti, all'età di 20 anni
pure io ho cercato di prendere distanza
e liberarmi da questa modalità.
Infatti mi sono sposata,
sono andata a vivere in città
in un appartamento
all'interno di una palazzina,
dove conoscevo solo alcune famiglie.
Però, poi è arrivato un giorno
in cui ho fatto un'esperienza
abbastanza forte e prolungata
che mi ha fatto rivalutare
il valore che ha
abitare in un luogo
dove tutti si conoscono e si aiutano.
Sono stati i 10 anni
in cui mio padre, gradualmente,
ha perso la sua memoria.
In quel periodo,
ricordo che guardavo mamma
e osservavo il suo disagio,
ascoltavo il suo senso di vuoto.
Insieme ai miei fratelli
cercavamo di colmare
quella sua sensazione di solitudine.
Ma è stato grazie a quell'aiuto,
offerto gratuitamente
dagli abitanti del borgo,
che ho capito l'importanza di una
partecipazione condivisa tra famiglie.
Poi, è arrivato il giorno
che i miei genitori non ci sono più.
E allora ho capito
che potevo fare qualcosa,
e ho iniziato a gettare
le basi per un modello
che potesse assomigliare a ciò
che io avevo fatto come esperienza;
o meglio, ho piantato semi veramente,
perché le persone possano
coltivare, quotidianamente,
connessioni con la natura
e con le persone.
Vedete, oggi siamo in un mondo -
Internet, e lo smartphone,
ci mettono collegati un po' con tutti.
Pensiamo di avere una rete diffusa
di colleghi, amici, parenti, conoscenti.
Quindi dici: vabbè,
è impossibile che resti sola,
basta avere un telefonino in mano
e tante persone a cui contattare.
Ma di recente, tutti noi
abbiamo fatto un'esperienza
che forse questo lo ha fatto
un attimino rivedere:
ricordate cosa è successo
durante il periodo di lockdown?
Cosa abbiamo capito?
Abbiamo capito che abbiamo
bisogno di contatti,
abbiamo la necessità fisica
di un abbraccio,
di salutare qualcuno
stringendogli la mano,
di mostrare il nostro affetto
attraverso un bacio.
Abbiamo capito che le sole
connessioni virtuali non bastano:
e allora, molti di noi hanno iniziato
a parlare con il vicino accanto,
a prendersi cura della signora
che abitava magari da sola,
lì nel palazzo,
e aveva bisogno di fare la spesa.
E allora, chiedevamo se era una necessità,
mentre andavamo a fare la spesa per noi.
Ci siamo uniti nella catena di applausi
da dedicare ai medici e agli infermieri
che erano impegnati a salvare vite umane.
Abbiamo cantato la stessa canzone,
nello stesso momento,
in tutte le città del paese,
pur di sentirci in un abbraccio condiviso.
Sono nata immersa nella natura,
ho conosciuto Il sapore, ed il valore,
di mangiare ciò che mio nonno
produceva nell'orto
in base alle stagioni.
Motivo per cui non riesco
ad immaginare il mio modello
senza del terreno da dedicare
ad una coltivazione biologica e sinergica.
Ci sono un'infinità di ricerche
medico-scientifiche
che portano in evidenza
l'importanza di mangiare cibi sani,
per nutrire la nostra salute.
Si promuove l'uso di alimenti
a chilometro zero.
Prediligere i frutti di stagione.
Questo perché?
Perché se mangi in modo sano,
se scegli cibi di stagione
coltivati in modo sano,
nutri il valore più importante:
nutriamo tutti noi, la nostra salute.
Sono stati tutti questi valori,
e la lettura,
ed i benefici, i vantaggi
che avevo vissuto
in quell'esperienza che avevo fatto,
ad accendere in me questa intuizione
di unire l'agricoltura e il cohousing,
creando il modello "agri cohousing".
Un modello che oggi permette
di abitare i luoghi,
innanzitutto riutilizzando
il patrimonio edilizio
degli edifici rurali abbandonati.
Ma è anche un posto
che consente di abbattere i costi
dell'abitare in una casa singola.
Avere opportunità
di un'occupazione di lavoro.
Riuscire ad avere a fine anno un reddito,
grazie alla condivisione
degli spazi condivisi.
Ma non solo:
è un modello che consente di abitare
in un posto dove puoi contare
su valide persone
che ti possono aiutare
nella gestione quotidiana
di figli e persone anziane.
Un luogo dove la connessione
con la natura, e con le persone,
si allena tutti i giorni.
Un posto in cui nutrire e arricchire,
naturalmente, le proprie relazioni.
Un luogo, quanto meno
questo è il modello che sogno,
dove realmente i sensi
sono tutti attivati.
Dove guardo, dove ascolto,
dove respiro, dove tocco con mano,
dove riuscire ad assaporare
le bontà di ogni stagione.
Un luogo dove il seme
dell'individualità, naturalmente,
si trasforma in opportunità
di vivere momenti ricchi
di colore e sapore.
Vi lascio, e chiudo il mio intervento
con questo proverbio africano:
"Se le formiche si mettono d'accordo,
possono spostare un elefante".
A me piace dire:
"L'unione non fa solo la forza,
l'unione aiuta a fare la differenza".
(Applausi)